the chiefs as we discussed earlier this
week peter had
177 dollars in cap space not 177
177. they have more now according to
yahoo sports they have ex not extended
but reworked the contract of receiver
sammy watkins creating 5 million in cap
space by reducing his base salary to 9
million he can reach 16 million with
incentives but
those incentives are probably pretty
high and they probably far exceed the
production we've seen from him so far in
two seasons with the chiefs look this
makes sense for everyone they weren't
going to trade his 14 million dollar
base salary he was going to get cut if
he didn't take less money he's taken
less money he stays with the chiefs and
he continues to be an important part of
that offense even if he isn't racking up
huge numbers
you know the great thing for the chiefs
is that they got uh sami watkins at a
very manageable number now for everybody
who said man
that's pretty good a pretty good deal
for the chiefs
watkins has been a great receiver at
times and i and i would say to him let's
just hang on for a minute sami watkins
over the last four years of his career
his average 37 catches and four
touchdowns a year
i mean come on sammy watkins is a nice
piece to have to your jigsaw puzzle
but in my opinion right now
it's you know they they have now
retained
their major forces in their offense like
in my opinion
when uh you know when eric b enemy when
you know when uh frank kafka and andy
reed when they start sitting in and
making their game plan you know they're
gonna have a tremendous advantage over
the rest of the league you know why
because not only do you have mahomes
back okay and there is your guy but
every one of his top four weapons or
every i'm sorry every one of his top
five weapons is now under contract for
this year tyreek hill travis kelsey
watkins robinson and obviously machole
hardman now mike
what an advantage
that is
in this time and place
that first of all you played later in
the year than anybody else okay you
played into february now you'll have all
this time off but when you gather
you're not going to have to have a team
that's going to learn a new offense or
anything like that this is a great move
for the kansas city chiefs
absolutely critical point the
learning curve is going to be
far easier for the teams who have
continuity and there's the continuity
with sami watkins and look i had been
suggesting maybe a trade during the
draft of sammy watkins which in theory
isn't out of the question the contract
is more tradable now but the thing is
with so many great young receivers in
the draft i don't see anyone giving up a
significant uh package to the chiefs for
watkins and they should want him and at
9 million that's more in line with where
he is and what he means and even though
his regular season production hasn't
been great he had 288 yards in the
postseason this year and he had one of
the most important plays of super bowl
54 when he relied upon what he saw from
devonta adams in the nfc championship
game against richard sherman to get
inside of sherman for a long catch at a
key moment of the fourth quarter
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports